que ça peut être utile
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image battu d'une icône absolue d'un
dieu vivant parce qu'il a porté très
haut les couleurs d'un pays qui était
humiliée par la guerre des malouines ce
pays a gagné la coupe du monde alors
c'est pas une victoire militaire mais
c'est une revanche politique et sportif
sur une défaite militaire parce que la
politique et le sport font finalement
bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique dit c'était un homme dutra
gauche on connaît sa proximité avec
castro on connaît sa proximité avec hugo
chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central vous êtes en
train de dire finalement diego maradona
c'est l'homme du passé ce cap a un côté
paradoxal le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que le personnage n'est pas lisse
et qu'il a de multiples aspérités et
c'est pour ça que c'est un personnage de
légende
[Musique]
à la une la france qui suspend tous les
déplacements et pour le fret en
provenance du royaume uni pour 48 heures
une décision prise en conseil de défense
sanitaire par visio conférence présidée
par emmanuel macron positif un rappel
aux copies 19 cette décision intervient
dans la foulée de mesures similaires
prises par la belgique les pays bas
l'italie l'allemagne ou l'irlande
pour faire face à une variante du virus
sascoc 2 détecté outre manche et selon
berlin les vaccins restent efficaces
contre la nouvelle souche à j - 11 avant
la date limite pour trouver un accord
post vrai qu site l'aude il se rapproche
aujourd'hui les discussions entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
bloque toujours sur la question de la
pêche
s'il n'y a pas d'accord d'ici le 31
décembre à minuit les échanges
britannique se feront selon les règles
de l'organisation mondiale du commerce
et puis les tensions en république
centrafricaine à une semaine des
élections générales la situation serait
sous contrôle a selon la force de l'onu
qui assure que les rebelles sont bloqués
ou repoussés de son côté la coalition de
l'opposition exigent le report des
scrutins prévus le 27 décembre après les
accusations de tentative de coup d'état
à l'encontre de l'ex président françois
bozizé dans la candidature a été rejetée
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france suspension pour
48 heures des trajets en provenance du
royaume-uni vers la france à emmanuel
macron a donné cet après midi à un
conseil de défense par visioconférence
afin de prendre des mesures contre la
nouvelle souche du coronavirus plus
contagieuse une variante en provenance
du royaume uni à la france qui gèle tous
les déplacements donc en provenance
d'outré manche pour les prochaines 48
heures compte tenu du risque sanitaire
nouveau et dans la tente de son
évaluation
l'ensemble des flux de personnes du
royaume uni vers la france sont
suspendues à partir de ce soir minuit
pour 48 heures
et pour tous les moyens de transport
nous invitons l'ensemble des
ressortissants français a réalisé un
test pcr qui pourra être exigée pour
toute entrée sur le territoire français
à partir du royaume-uni à l'issue du
délai de précaution de 48 heures
ce délai de deux jours permettra
d'assurer une coordination avec nos
partenaires européens pour aboutir à une
réponse commune de faire la clarté sur
la situation sanitaire outre-manche de
travailler à une solution adaptée pour
nos ressortissants présents au royaume
uni et plusieurs pays dont l'allemagne
et l'irlande et ce soir minuit
suspendent leurs vols en provenance et à
destination du royaume uni ont fait donc
le point avec un média ce qui fit une
nouvelle souche du corona virus
identifié au royaume uni ce qui pourrait
se transmettre bien plus facilement que
la précédente
une découverte qui inquiète aujourd'hui
la communauté internationale et qui
pousse certains pays et à prendre des
dispositions en urgence ce dimanche
paris et berlin s'entretiennent avec lui
et eux pour une coordination sur ce
dossier plusieurs pays européens dont
l'allemagne les pays-bas ou encore la
belgique ont déjà suspendu les vols en
provenance du royaume uni les autorités
néerlandaises sont particulièrement
inquiètes une mutation infectieuses du
virus du coc vie 19 est en circulation
royaume uni ont dit qu elle se diffuse
plus facilement et plus vite et qu'elle
est plus difficile à détecter
au cours des prochains jours avec
d'autres pays membres de l'union
européenne
le gouvernement néerlandais
explorera les possibilités de limiter
davantage le risque que la nouvelle
souche du virus ne soit importé du
royaume uni d'autres pays européens
songent sérieusement à couper les
liaisons aériennes avec le territoire
britannique
des précautions qui interviennent peu de
temps après leur confinement du royaume
uni annoncée par boris johnson
cette nouvelle variante du coc vide 19
inquiète également les autorités
britanniques
malheureusement la nouvelle souche et
est hors de contrôle
nous devions reprendre le contrôle et la
seule manière de le faire est de
restreindre les contacts sociaux
ce sera très difficile de la garder sous
contrôle jusqu'à ce qu'un vaccin soit
déployé une autre souche du virus a été
découverte
cette fois ci en afrique du sud face à
ces nouvelles alertes l' oms europe
appelle ses membres à renforcer leurs
contrôles de manière à éviter nouvelle
aggravation de la crise sanitaire au
royaume uni londres et le sud du pays
roux confine donc des mesures de
restriction qui ne plaisent pas à tout
le monde
en témoigne ce rassemblement hier sur la
place du parlement dans la capitale
avant de tenter à deux marchés pour ces
manifestants jusqu'à trafalgar square
des échauffourées ont eu lieu entre
protestataires et policiers à la police
qui avait publié un communiqué exhortant
la population à hésiter à les grands
rassemblements et elle a procédé à une
vingtaine d'arrestations et selon berlin
les vaccins restent efficaces contre la
nouvelle souche détectée au royaume uni
en tout cas pour philippe froguel
chercheur généticien et professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 à cette nouvelle
souche elle a effectivement de quoi
inquiéter sur les calls
celle ci est inquiétante parce que la
mutation
certaines correspondant aussi
d'entraîneur du virus dans la cellule
humaine et d'autres peut-être encore
plus inquiétante au niveau de la
production d'une protéine qui s'appelle
spike et justement la protéine qui est
visé par les vaccins actuels ceux de
pfizer et de modern là donc c'est normal
qu'ils aient une inquiétude en france
l'an passé est ennuyeux c'est qu'on n'a
pas du tout fait comme en angleterre et
ne sait quand ce pas
systématiquement les souches avec
exception de liège sud de marseille
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit
capable de savoir précisément et
rapidement ce qui se passe ce qui se
passe en france
quant à éviter que le virus dissémine
l'angleterre à la france un pays luzoir
moi j'étais dans l'eurostar vendredi
c'était bondé et quelqu'un est affecté
là bas je vois pas comment on va
vraiment empêché les indices terminent
en france et dans ce contexte
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'union européenne appelle à renforcer
les contrôles en europe qui fait face en
plus à un rebond épidémique en cette
période de fin d'année est propice à la
circulation active du virus plusieurs
pays ont décidé des mesures de
confinement partiel ou total l'allemagne
l'autriche par exemple et en italie
l'euro confinement il entre en vigueur
dès demain tout le pays est classé en
zone rouge les déplacements ils seront
interdits à l'exception d'une sortie par
jour à l'intérieur de sa propre région
on écoute le premier ministre italien
giuseppe quand et nous devons intervenir
et ce n'est pas une décision facile
c'est une décision difficile à prendre
pour renforcer les mesures nécessaires
pour faire face aux prochaines vacances
et pour nous protéger également en vue
de la reprise des activités en janvier
alors que les campagnes de vaccination
démarre dans un certain nombre de pays
l'union européenne
pour l'instant on n'a pas donné son feu
vert pour le vaccin father biotech
c'est un télé que lui reprocherait
d'ailleurs plusieurs membres de l'union
européenne notamment
alors pour accélérer le processus l'
agence européenne des médicaments avant
c'est une réunion qui se tiendra
finalement
ce lundi elle doit permettre à lagence
de se prononcer sur le sort du vaccin
les explications avec thomas bonus en
voyant ces images d'injection arrivée de
plusieurs pays du globe
certains en europe commencent à
s'impatienter pourquoi les états unis
israël ou encore le royaume-uni aurait
le droit de commencer leur campagne de
vaccination n'est pas l'allemagne ou la
france
la réponse est entre les mains de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
habituellement prudente l'agencé a été
priée d'accélérer son calendrier comme
le révèle cet article de reuters des
pressions auraient été exercées ces
derniers jours alors que l'europe
connaît une accélération des
contaminations pressé d'approuver plus
rapidement les vaccins l' agence
européenne des médicaments a pris la
décision d'organiser une réunion
exceptionnelle son comité se retrouvera
à ce lundi 21 décembre
huit jours plus tôt que prévu le chmp
rendra ses conclusions le plus tôt
possible et seulement lorsque les
données sur la qualité la sécurité et
l'efficacité du vaccin seront
suffisamment solide et complète pour
déterminer si les bénéfices du vaccin
dépasse les risques une décision qui
fait suite aux requêtes répétées de
certains acteurs européens l'allemagne
en tête touché fortement par une
deuxième vague le pays se montrent
pressants quant à la possibilité de
vacciner
le ministre allemand de la santé impose
son calendrier
notre objectif est une approbation avant
noël mon boulot toujours commencer à
vacciner cette année en allemagne avant
la fin de l'année une accélération qui
pourrait s'avérer contre-productive
la défiance des européens envers les
vaccins est forte donner le sentiment
d'un passage en force pourrait renforcer
l'hésitation de la population dans
d'autres pays
les dirigeants ont voulu montrer
l'exemple en se faisant vacciner
pas sûr que cela suffise en europe où
les mesures restrictives ont de plus en
plus de mal à passer
la france devrait être entamé de son
côté sa campagne de vaccination fin
décembre en israël ça a déjà commencé
premier à recevoir une injection hier
denali netanyahu vous le voyez le
premier ministre israélien a dit vouloir
donner l'exemple à ses 9 millions de
concitoyens à l'état hébreu recense
trois cent soixante dix mille cas pour
plus de 3000 décès israël a commandé
plusieurs millions de doses du vaccin de
l'alliance germano américaine a father
bien tête
c'est un grand jour pour l'état d'israël
nous vivons depuis près d'un an avec la
pandémie la plus difficile que
l'humanité ait connu au cours des 100
dernières années et c'est le début de l'
issue nous avons acheté des millions de
vaccins jusqu'à la fin du mois des
millions de vaccins arriveront dans
notre petit état d'israël
ce n'est pas banal des millions d'autres
sont à venir et tout le monde doit se
faire vacciner
j'ai demandé me faire vacciner d'abord
avec le ministre de la santé youli
edelstein afin de donner un exemple
personnel et de vous encourager à vous
faire vacciner
on peut s'en sortir ensemble et puis
regardez ces images en thaïlande
aujourd'hui où des milliers de personnes
se sont ruées vers des centres de
dépistage dans une province à de bangkok
de longues files d'attentes sur une
centaine de mètres dépistage massif
conséquence donc atteint un nouveau
foyer contamination est détectée dans un
marché aux fruits de mer
plus de 700 personnes ont été testées
positives dans ce nouveau cluster créant
la panique d'ailleurs chez les riverains
à les autorités locales ont décrété un
couvre-feu nocturne dans la région
jusqu'au 3 janvier chien je suis très
inquiète
j'ai très peur parce que ces six proches
la dernière fois j'avais l'impression
que c'était loin mais cette fois c'est
si près que je ne quitte pas la maison
je me demande si je vais l'attraper
je suis inquiète parce que je ne peux
rien faire du tout et que mes employés
ne peuvent pas sortir non plus donc nous
ne pouvons rien faire
la perte est énorme comment puis-je
vivre comme ça le virus arrive mais je
ne peux pas le voir si quelque chose
m'arrive
ce sera compliqué je voulais partir et
hier soir parce que j'ai passé le test
mais j'ai décidé d'attendre ce matin
parce que je ne pouvais pas faire mes
valises à temps la perspective d'un
odile se rapprochent londres et
bruxelles mènent d'ultimes négociations
post break site avant la date butoir du
31 décembre
et parmi les points d'achoppement la
pêche on le rappelle à 6,1 odile à est
apte et londres et bruxelles
commerceront avec les règles de l'om
c'est à jordy de maurice les discussions
en cours ont permis quelques avancées
mais des difficultés subsistent toujours
concernant la pêche et l'accès aux eaux
britanniques londres et bruxelles ne
parviennent pas à s'entendre par exemple
sur la réduction des volumes pêchés
ainsi que sur la durée de la période de
transition durant laquelle ses quotas
serait appliqué le royaume uni propose
que lui renonce à 60% des 650 millions
d'euros tirées des eaux britanniques et
envisage une renégociation d'ici trois
ans bruxelles compte laisser filer
seulement 15 à 18% des volumes actuels
et ce pour une durée beaucoup plus
longue de 8 à 10 ans l'appel ce jeudi
entre boris johnson et ursula von der
leyen ne s'est pas conclue par un accord
concernant ce secteur un blocage
confirmée le lendemain par le premier
ministre britannique dans une nouvelle
sortie qui occupent notre porte est
ouverte nous continuerons à discuter
mais je dois dire que la situation
semble difficile et qu'il y à un fossé à
combler le royaume uni a fait beaucoup
je pense pour essayer d'aider et nous
espérons que nos amis de l'union
européenne reviendront à la raison et
viendront ce même à la table des
négociations avec quelque chose c'est
vraiment là que nous en sommes de son
côté le parlement européen a averti
vouloir un accord d'ici ce dimanche
minuit
afin de pouvoir l'examiner le ratifier
pour qu'il puisse entrer en vigueur le
1er janvier
nous sommes à un moment de vérité il
nous reste très peu de temps quelques
heures utile dans cette négociation
si nous voulons que cet accord entre en
vigueur le 1er janvier
voilà pourquoi nous devons être prêts à
tous les scénarios voilà pourquoi aussi
est soumis à votre vote une série de
textes comportant des mesures de
contrainte gêne si pour nous préparer à
un éventuel no deal ce vendredi les
eurodéputés ont donc voté une série de
mesures jugées indispensables pour
assurer la fluidité des transports et de
la pêche dite de contingence elles
doivent pouvoir entrer en application
dès le premier jour de l'année 2021 et
serait activé seulement en cas d'échec
des négociations ou si un accord était
scellé dans les tous derniers jours du
mois de décembre
en attendant une éventuelle issue
favorable aux négociations les files
d'attentes de camions s'allonge des deux
côtés de la manche
c'est un projet qui ne passe pas le
projet recul qui prévoit une
réorganisation à d'edf géant devrait
ainsi être scindée en trois entités est
les syndicats appellent à la grève et
craignent une remise en cause des
conditions de travail des salariés du
côté des politiques
on souligne un danger pour la
souveraineté énergétique du pays
on voit cela avec estelle tâche projet
hercules c'est le nom de code de ce
chantier qui a pour but de réorganiser
edf
objectif diviser électricité de france
en trois filiales edf bleus détenue à
100% par l'état
cette première entité regrouperait
toutes les activités nucléaires et rte
le réseau de transport de l'électricité
edf vers celle ci pourrait être cotée en
bourse comprendrait les activités
commerciales du groupe et serait en
charge des énergies renouvelables enfin
edf azur pour tout le secteur des
barrages hydrauliques unanimes dans leur
rejet de ce projet les syndicats du
groupe edf estime qu'il comporte je cite
de multiples dangers notamment parce
qu'ils y voient un démantèlement du
groupe et ont donc organisé plusieurs
actions pour dire non
hercules le projet recul s'inscrit dans
un processus de déconstruction
méthodique d'un monopole public dont
tout le monde reconnaissait pourtant le
succès de son côté le gouvernement nie
toute volonté de démantèlement
le souhait du gouvernement n'est
évidemment pas de déstabiliser un des
fleurons industriels français
seulement nous devons nous assurer que
le groupe dispose d'un cadre de
régulation adaptée et de capacité
d'investissement qui sont accrus pour
participer pleinement à la transition en
toile de fond de ce projet et recul il y
à ces négociations entre paris et
bruxelles
elles concernent notamment le prix du
nucléaire depuis 2011
edf est sous le coup du dispositif à
rennes pour accès régulé à l'énergie
nucléaire historique
il oblige le groupe à vendre à un prix
fixe un quart de sa production
d'électricité issue du nucléaire à ses
concurrents
1 mégawatt heure se vend donc
aujourd'hui à 42 euros trop peu pour edf
qui peinent à lancer des investissements
mais augmenter ce prix de vente
reviendrait pour la commission
européenne a entravé les règles de l'ue
eu un coup de pouce de l'état qu'elle
assimile à une entrave à la libre
concurrence
d'où ce projet hercules voulue par
l'état grâce auquel la filière edf bleus
pourraient revendre sa production issue
du nucléaire edf verts dont les mêmes
conditions qu'à ses concurrents hercules
a aussi provoqué une levée de boucliers
au sein de la classe politique à
l'assemblée nationale les parlementaires
socialistes proposent ainsi un
référendum d'initiative partagée pour
contrer ce projet un projet est
également très critiqué par les élus des
groupes les républicains et la france
est soumise
les socialistes de l'assemblée nationale
et les sénateurs ps propose aujourd'hui
un référendum d'initiative partagée pour
empêcher le démantèlement d'edf en
cassant edf le gouvernement affaibli la
souveraineté de notre pays est le
principal outil de notre transition
énergétique
cette séparation des activités fait
peser un risque inacceptable sur la
souveraineté du pays
où est la logique monsieur le premier
ministre et l industrielles ou
financières
ce projet d'achèvement du démantèlement
d'edf appelé hercules l'idée du projet
recul c'est de continuer et de finir de
saucissonner le groupe en deux grandes
entités
d'un côté vous auriez edf bleus une
entité qui resterait public et dans
laquelle on mettrait tout ce qui coûte
très cher et qui nécessite des
investissements colossaux pour être
entretenue par exemple le nucléaire et
de l'autre vous auriez une société
ouverte au capital privé
edf fr dans lequel il mettrait tout ce
qui peut rapporter de l'argent
de leur côté les syndicats entendent
continuer leur action ils en ont
organisé de nouvelles cette semaine à
travers le pays
écoutez à présent la réaction de
sébastien jumel et le député gauche
démocratique et républicaine de la 6e
circonscription de seine maritime pour
lui ce projet relève d'une vieille
doctrine libérale
on doit y voir une fois de plus les
vieilles doctrines libérales le
renoncement à la fumée des prérogatives
d'état stratège j'ajoute que en se
débarrassant en ouvrant le capital privé
des énergies renouvelables l'état se
prive d'outils qui du père mathy compris
de lutter efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique tant qu' on est
dans une logique qui vise à faire
plaisir à des actionnaires privés aux
concurrents d'edf et à s'inscrire dans
l'esprit du traité européen de
concurrence libre et non faussée
c'est purement idéologique même l'ancien
président d'edf monsieur proglio qui
n'est pas réputé pour être proche des
communistes considèrent que c'est une
erreur stratégique une erreur industriel
in heureux pour l'état souverain est
toujours d'en être ré capin de la
semaine la dernière poutine a répondu
pendant plus de quatre heures aux
questions des médias un exercice que le
président russe affectionne
particulièrement
une prise de parole par visioconférence
crise sanitaire à oblige à les
précisions de notre correspondant à
moscou antoine cléroux l'exercice aura
duré cette année 4h30 une conférence de
presse lors de laquelle de très nombreux
sujets ont été évoqués avec en premier
lieu bien entendu cette pandémie de
covile 19
il était question du système de santé
russes et sa capacité à s'adapter de
l'impact de cette crise sanitaire sur
l'économie ou encore des vaccins
développé par la russie ce propos un
journaliste a même posé la question
suivante à vladmir poutine
monsieur le président allez-vous vous
faire vacciner les vaccins qui sont en
circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge et pour
l'instant les gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie
mais je respecte la loi je suis les
recommandations de nos spécialistes est
pour l'instant moi je me suis fais pas
je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je le
ferai dès que ce sera possible
il a largement été question du coc vide
vladimir poutine a au passage souhaité
un prompt rétablissement à emmanuel
macron en marge de cette conférence de
presse mais de nombreux thèmes de
l'actualité internationale ont aussi été
abordés on peut citer par exemple les
situations dans le haut-karabagh en
ukraine ou encore en biélorussie
vladimir poutine a également dit vouloir
améliorer les relations entre la russie
et les etats unis avec l'arrivée de joe
biden à la maison blanche notamment via
le renouvellement du traité new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques
la ferme la valley a elle aussi été
évoquée avec les dernières accusations
de médias occidentaux qui mettent en
cause des agents du fsb
écoutez je dirais que je patients de la
clinique bernoise
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
synthes endroit ça veut dire
qu'effectivement les services secrets
doivent su suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors l'enquêté peut-être
peut-être pas
achevée il faut la possession son épouse
a demandé à pouvoir le suivre en
allemagne j'ai donné l'autorisation
enfin interrogé sur les chefs d'état
étrangers avec qui ils apprécient
négocier échangés le président russe a
donné de nom le dirigeant chinois xi
jinping avec qui il dit entretenir une
relation d'amitié et le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan
chez qu'il apprécie le franc parler il
est vrai que les deux hommes s'opposent
sur de nombreux dossiers mais arrive
toujours à communiquer à s'entendre de
façon concrète
c'est ainsi que s'est terminée cette
conférence de presse au format
inhabituel certes mais qui aura permis à
vladimir poutine de s'exprimer sur de
très nombreux sujets en république
centrafricaine la situation serait sous
contrôle selon la force de l'onu qui
assure que les rebelles sont bloqués ou
repoussé à une semaine des élections
générales
la coalition de l'opposition a exigé
aujourd'hui le report des scrutins
prévus le 27 décembre prochain
et hier le gouvernement a accusé
l'ancien président françois bozizé d'une
tentative de coup d'état avec l'appui
des groupes armés sont partis a démenti
et puis de son côté elle lors d'un
meeting le président candidat à sa
propre succession faustin archange
touadéra a réaffirmé son attachement au
processus électoral maintient à des
scrutins à la date prévue
l'autorité nationale des élections et la
cour constitutionnelle ont assuré que
les élections se tiendront dans les
temps
c'est par la démocratie qu notre pays
connaîtra le développement pourquoi à
prendre les armes contre des
compatriotes
j'appelle les jeunes à la vigilance
soyez vigilants je vous remercie
et les centrafricains sont de plus en
plus inquiet par rapport à la situation
politique dans leur pays et coûté à
certains d'entre eux des propos
recueillis dans la capitale bangui à
tous les candidats qui profite le cours
de la présidentielle et législative de
se maîtriser et c'est gagné et se
comporter comme de bons citoyens
[Applaudissements]
de là
ces quelques
la peur
les afpa
le pénis est pas tout le monde qui
bien aller
comme il ya moins de bière ça va aller
chez les groupes allaient à chaque fois
en suis à chaque fois au qc ca
on a ce que c'est
change
qui à chaque fois d'une édition
amen
deuxième raison politique
pour sa lutte
son s'entendent bien qu'on nous pose sur
un autorisé en hausse en clôture et pour
yoakim kokaté conseiller spécial de la
présidence centrafricaine tout est mis
en oeuvre en ce moment pour pouvoir
permettre le bon déroulement des
élections dans le pays on écoute mois
avant que le fonds est du côté du globe
et tous nous sommes assurés que les
élections auront lieu à ce que les
conditions soient réunies a vendu dans
les arrières pays donc il y aura des
élections
qu'est ce qu'on voit là il avait des
restes à la noix et nous sommes en train
de mettre hors d'état de nuire tout le
punch durée du temps et puis cette
nouvelle attaque au nigeria dans le nord
ouest
après plusieurs centaines d'enfants
enlevés ces derniers jours par boko
haram cette fois ce sont cinq militaires
ont été tués et 35 civils kidnappés lors
de deux attaques 10 à dist selon des
sources sécuritaires
samedi soir des combattants armés de la
branche boko haram ont attaqué un convoi
de voitures transportant des civils dans
cette région épicentre de l'insurrection
islamiste
écoutez ces réactions d'habitants
nigériens mais passagers et moi nous
avons prié depuis le début de notre
voyage et nous avons également prier le
dieu puissant d'accorder le repos
éternel à ceux qui ont perdu la vie et
que dieu réunissent les personnes
enlevées avec leurs proches en effet la
route n'est pas sûr et doit être
reconstruite
d'habitude il nous fallait seulement une
heure pour aller à mes du gorille mais
maintenant il nous faut environ deux
heures parce que la route n'est pas sûr
nous appelons le gouvernement à injecter
davantage de fonds pour reconstruire la
route et a renforcé la sécurité dans la
région et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en
reste dans 30 minutes pour une nouvelle
édition rester avec nous sur rtl ans
[Musique]
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que notre
peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire 16 passes en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
des organes d'un flux ans de propagande
et de propagande mensongère montreuil
pour au château
[Musique]
alors non mais vous êtes fait la bête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais n'est pas fait à faire baisser